- The amount of people that decide
to spend all their
fucking time on pondering
and blaming is unbelievably high.
(light piano music)
What blows me away is how many of you
have decided that you're finished,
that you're on the backend of your life,
that you can't accomplish it.
When you start dwelling, you start looking
in the wrong direction.
Dwelling on what you fucked up on
is the quickest way for
the next thing not to work.
So many of your entrepreneurial
and just life ambitions
start to windle, your start settling in
to this is my life, this
is how it played out.
I could have, I should have.
Supposed to be a big time lawyer.
Supposed to marry the girl
or guy of their dreams.
Supposed to, supposed to, supposed to.
- Anyone listening to this
who's woe-is-me'ing right now.
- You know the problem with woe is me?
Nobody's fucking listening.
My friends, let me tell you
who's listening to you complain.
Either the two or three
people that kind of have to
'cause they're your parents,
or your other fuckin' losing friends.
Stop making fucking bullshit excuses.
Who the president is, your mom did this,
like I missed it, if anybody's made it
that looks like you, that's it, that's it.
So I think this is about making a decision
and not dwelling or pondering on what if
'cause what if's cripple people.
If you're saying to yourself,
"Fuck, then what do I do,"
you're never gonna know the alternative.
If I could just get you to realize
that looking backwards
and dwelling on the fact
that you didn't do it in
your 20's or your 30's
or your 40's actually means nothing.
The fact that you have a
half a century to get yours
in this technology world,
this isn't just for the kids,
my friends, this is our
opportunity as well.
You have a lot more time than you think.
It is super appropriate for
you to start that business
that you've always wanted right now.
You know, take some risks,
you've tasted some stuff.
Happiness is the ROY,
please get the I'm finished
or I fucked up, like eliminate dwelling
'cause you're just starting.
So instead of sitting in that
job for the next 10 years,
go do your thing, you've got
plenty and plenty of time.
Because the number one
thing that scares the fuck
out of me is regret, and
you're gonna sit there at 72.
And you're gonna say, "I
wish, I wish, I wish."
And whether that's
money or spend more time
with your family, there's
a million ways to do this.
Not everybody wants to buy the jets.
Not everybody wants to
smoke weed on the beach
in the Bahamas, like everybody's got
a different fuckin' thing.
Figure out what your fuckin' thing is
and stop making fucking bullshit excuses.
Go talk to five 90-year-olds.
If you really listen, all
you're gonna hear is regret.
Please make this video the call to action,
the spark that starts
the fire of your career
for the next 40 years.
(dramatic music)
I bet you.
I bet you to take a shot.
Roll up on that hot chick
in a bar and ask her out.
Roll up on that good lookin'
dude and ask him for coffee.
Roll up on your business
idea and make it happen
because being 50, 60,
70, 80, 90, and havin' regrets
that you didn't swing the bat,
that's the worse of them all.
That bat is in front of us, take a swing.
(light piano music)